OWNERS THAT HAVE SOMETHING THAT
THEY WANT TO SAY TO NEW ORLEANS
MAYOR, LATOYA CANTRELL.
FIRST, THE GOP’S GREAT RESET.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
NOW, WEEKS AGO THE ANGLE WARN
PELOSI AND COMPANY THAT
IMPEACHMENT WOULD HELP TRUMP.
THEY LISTENED TO THE CRAZIES
INSTEAD.
THE SECOND IMPEACHMENT FIASCO
WAS A TOTAL DISASTER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
TRUMP WAS ACQUITTED.
ZERO MINDS WERE CHANGED.
NOTHING WAS ACCOMPLISHED.
EXCEPT DONALD TRUMP EMERGED
STRONGER AND THE CONGRESS
WEAKER.
NOW, A RECENT POLL CONDUCTED BY
THE LIBERAL WEBSITE VOXX MADE
TWO IMPORTANT FINDINGS.
69% OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BECOME A
CANDIDATE TO VOTE TO CONVICT RUN
THE.
NUMBER 2, 70% OF LIKELY GOP
VOTERS SAY THEY WANT TO SEE
TRUMP RUN AGAIN IN 2024.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO TRY TO GOVERN AT THIS POINT,
RIGHT?
IMPEACHMENT BEHIND THEM.
WHICH THEY HAVE PROVEN
THEMSELVES TO BE SUPREMELY BAD
AT DOING.
AFTER ALL, IF THEY CAN GOVERN,
AMERICAN’S WOULD BE FLEEING
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE RELYING ON
TRUMP’S PRESENCE AND VIRUS PANIC
AND SHIELDS TO COVER THEIR
ONGOING DESTRUCTION TO OUR
ECONOMY, OUR BORDERS AND OUR
FOREIGN POLICY.
AFTER ONE MONTH IN OFFICE -- CAN
YOU BELIEVE IT’S BEEN A MONTH?
THE VEIL OR FACE MASK IS OFF.
MORE AMERICANS ARE SEEING
EXACTLY WHO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
AND WHAT THEY INTEND TO DO TO
AMERICA.
THIS DEVELOPMENT PRESENTS A
CLEAR OPENING FOR THE GOP.
TEN YEARS AFTER THE TEA PARTY
MOVE REARED UP THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE OLD GOP ESTABLISHMENT, A
POPULOUS AMERICAN FIRST MOVEMENT
IS NOW THE UNDENIABLE CORE OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SO NO MATTER HOW OFTEN JEFF
FLAKE OR THE SLEEPY LINCOLN
PROJECT DRIFTERS APPEAR ON
MSNBC, WE AIN’T GOING BACK TO
REPUBLICANISM.
NO MORE SUPPORT FOR OPEN
BORDERS, NO MORE BLANK CHECKS
FOR ENDLESS WARS, NO MORE
PUTTING CHINA AND MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS FIRST.
NEVER AGAIN.
THAT VERSION OF THE GOP IS
FINISHED.
WITH MUCH OF THE OLD
ESTABLISHMENT ON THE SIDELINES
THOUGH, THE GOP IS FREE NOW TO
REPRESENT ITS VOTERS.
THAT’S A NEW CONCEPT.
THAT MEANS AGGRESSIVELY
ADVANCING A PRO GROWTH
ANTI-LOCKDOWN AGENDA THAT PUTS
AMERICAN FAMILIES FIRST.
NOW, WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW THAT WILL HELP
OUR COUNTRY AND GROW OUR
MOVEMENT?
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS I
THINK ALL OF US TOGETHER WHAT
NOW?
TEN MONTHS?
OPENING SCHOOLS.
THE DEMOCRATS’ STANCE OR
REOPENING SCHOOLS IS
ANTI-SCIENCE AND JUST PLAIN EVIL
AT THIS POINT.
IT ONCE IN ALL PROVES THAT
DEMOCRATS DON’T GIVE A RIP ABOUT
CHILDREN THAT DON’T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND PRIVATE
ACADEMIES.
IF YOU EVER DOUBTED THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST PUPPETS OF
THE TEACHER’S UNION?
YOU DIDN’T TRUST THIS SHOW.
YOU SHOULD HAVE.
BUT NOW YOU KNOW THE UGLY TRUTH.
>> MY TEAM WILL WORK TO SEE THE
MAJORITY OF OUR SCHOOLS CAN BE
OPENED BY THE END OF MY FIRST
100 DAYS.
THAT’S RIGHT.
>> HIS RULE THAT HE SET IS TO
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF SCHOOLS,
MORE THAN 500% OPEN BY DAY 100
OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
TEACHING AT LEAST ONE DAY A
WEEK.
>> I THINK THE SCHOOLS NEED MORE
RESOURCES.
THAT’S THE REASON WHY THE
NATIONAL RELIEF ACT THAT WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING PASSED, WE
NEED THAT.
>> Laura: THAT’S A COMPLETE AND
UTTER JOKE.
EVEN JAKE TAPPER, THAT HAS
CANNONIZED ANTHONY FAUCI, HE
TEARED UP REALIZING SCHOOLS
WEREN’T OPENING ANY TIME SOON.
>> I FEEL DISSPIRITED AFTER THIS
CONVERSATION.
I HAD HIGH HOPES THAT SCHOOLS
WOULD RESUME IN-PERSON LEARNING
BECAUSE SO MANY SCIENTISTS AND
HEALTH OFFICIALS INCLUDING YOU
AND DR. FAUCI AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE SCIENCE
SUPPORTS OPENING THE SCHOOLS.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU’RE ASKING FOR
100% MASK COMPLIANCE AND A NEW
OF MEASURES THAT WE’LL NEVER
ACHIEVE.
THAT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE BOY, I
DON’T KNOW IF THE SCHOOLS WILL
EVER OPEN.
>> Laura: DUH!
OF COURSE THEY’RE NOT.
THEY DON’T WANT THEM TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL UNLESS THE TEACHERS
ARE FORCED TO DO SO.
NOW, THEY CAN BUY EVERY TEACHER
A FULL SPACESUIT AND VACCINATE
THEM AND INSTALL HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF NEW HVAC
SYSTEMS IN SCHOOLS.
FAUCI AND BIDEN WOULD JUST MOVE
ON TO SQUAWKING ABOUT ANOTHER
VIRUS MUTATION IS COMING.
YOU REALLY THINK THE GOP IS
GOING TO LOSE GROUND TO A PARTY
THAT WANTS TO KEEP KIDS STUCK AT
HOME FOREVER?
COME ON, MAN!
HOW MUCH LONGER WILL YOUNG
VOTERS IN BLUE STATES LIKE
MICHIGAN, ILLINOIS, NEW YORK AND
CONNECTICUT TOLERATE THE BLEED
OF BUSINESSES FROM THEIR ALREADY
HIGH TAXED PRO SHUT-DOWN STATES?
WHO IN THEIR RIGHT MIND WOULD
TAKE ON THE COVID BLAME-SHIFTING
PERFORMANCE FROM ANDREW CUOMO?
>> IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU
PERSONALLY APOLOGIZE FOR IN THIS
PROCESS?
>> APOLOGIZE?
LOOK, I HAVE SAID REPEATEDLY WE
MADE A MISTAKE IN CREATING THE
VOID WHEN WE DIDN’T PROVIDE
INFORMATION.
IT ALLOWED PRESS, PEOPLE,
CYNICS, POLITICIANS TO FILL THE
VOID.
>> Laura: GIVE THAT MAN ANOTHER
EMMY.
FOR YEARS, REPUBLICANS HAVE
TREATED CALIFORNIA AS IF IT’S A
LOST CAUSE.
NEW YORK PRETTY MUCH THE SAME.
BUT LOOK WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW.
YOU GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THE
CALIFORNIAS THAT ARE WAKING UP
TO GRUESOME NEWSOME.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN THE 1.5
SIGNATURES TO RECALL HIM.
I BET THE DEMOCRAT PARTY WILL
OBJECT TO THOSE CERTIFICATIONS.
NOW, MEANWHILE, OUR POLICIES,
THE AMERICA FIRST POLICIES, THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
RED STATES LIKE FLORIDA, TEXAS,
SOUTH DAKOTA AND TENNESSEE, YES,
THEY’RE RISING.
THEY NIXED THE LOOKDOWN
MENTALITY AND UNDERSTOOD FROM
THE BEGINNING THAT THE CURE
YOU’D NOT BE WORSE NAN THE
DISEASE.
NOW, IT WAS LAST MAY, IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, WHEN THE
ANGLE PLEADED WITH THE DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS TO WAKE UP.
IT’S BECOMING MORE OBVIOUS BY
THE DAY THAT THESE POWER HUNGRY
GOVERNORS IN RADICAL MAYORS ARE
ENDANGERING THEIR STATE’S
FUTURES AND WILL EVENTUALLY SEE
THEIR STATES LEFT BEHIND.
THIS HAS BEEN THE PATTERN OF
BLUE STATE GOVERNORS AND RADICAL
MAYERS IN COVID-19.
THEY DON’T TRUST THEIR OWN
CITIZENS AND AT TIMES THEY SEEM
TO RELISH PUNISHING THEM.
BUT THEY WOULDN’T LISTEN.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO LISTEN.
AT SOME POINT ALONG THE WAY,
THIS WHOLE EFFORT STOPS BECOMING
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE VIRUS AND
IT COMES ABOUT CONTROLLING THE
PEOPLE.
OUR CHOICES, OUR TRAVEL, OUR
EDUCATION, OUR CHURCHES, OUR
FREE SPEECH.
ANYONE THAT QUESTIONED THE
VAUNTED MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT
WAS BRANDED AS ANTI-SCIENCE.
ALSO CALLED DANGEROUS.
WHEN THE HISTORY OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS FINELY WRITTEN, MANY
OF THE HEROS AND GENIUSES OF
TODAY WILL BE SEEN AS VILLAINS
OR INCOMPETENT LIKE THE DEMOCRAT
AND REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS THAT
SAW TRUMP AS A BIGGER THREAT
THAN THE CCP.
EVENTUALLY CONSERVATIVE LEADERS
LIKE RON DESANTIS, GREG ABBOTT
AND OF COURSE DONALD TRUMP WILL
BE SEEN AS VISIONARIES FOR DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO NOT
ONLY KEEP AMERICANS SAFE FROM A
VIRUS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY KEEP
THEM FREE.
AFTER A FEW MORE YEARS OF
LOCKDOWNS AND RACIAL GRIEVANCE,
GOVERNMENT CONTROLS AND DYING
STATE ECONOMIES, THE AMERICA
FIRST MESSAGE WILL RESONATE WITH
WOMEN, YOUNG AMERICANS, NEW
AMERICANS, LATINO AMERICANS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS.